how much does the US fund foreign armies
across northern Iraq an Islamist
militant group has been seizing
territory while the country's armed
forces have crumbled the United States
funded trained and armed that very same
military that's been melting away during
the eight years between invading Iraq in
2003 and withdrawing in 2011 US
taxpayers spent around 23 billion
dollars one military assistance there
Iraqi taxpayers match that number with
25 billion dollars from their own
national budget spent on defense the US
private sector has separately sold 3.4
billion dollars weapons to Iraq over the
past decade but that's a drop in the
ocean compared to u.s. public sector
spending on the Iraq war which a recent
study from Brown University put a 1.7
trillion dollars with trillions more to
be spent on coming years for veterans
care besides a-rod there are several
other major beneficiaries of US military
assistance Afghanistan where an average
of eight civilians were killed every day
last year has received 48 billion
dollars in military assistance since
nine eleven thirty 1 billion dollars
during that same period has flowed to
Israel with troubled Egypt receiving
about half that amount another neighbor
to Israel and the RAF Jordan which is
currently overwhelmed by a million-plus
refugees from Syria got three hundred
million dollars in u.s. military
assistance in 2012 that was equivalent
to a quarter of its own national defense
budget that year Pakistan has taken in
nearly seven billion dollars in military
assistance from the US since nine eleven
during a period in which some 20,000
Pakistanis have died in terrorist
violence in 2012 the last year for which
we have records more than 17 billion
dollars was sent to foreign militaries
but that's just a fraction of the 682
billion dollars spent by the US on the
fence over